fixez les grands objectifs énergétiques
de la France pour répondre aux défis de
du dérèglement climatique c'est
l'ambition qui est fixée par la future
loi de programmation sur l'énergie et le
climat la mise de la transition
énergétique Agnès panier à une hachée à
missionné cette groupes de travail qui
ont pu rendre il y a quelques jours une
centaine de conclusions sur le sujet
bonjour Jean-Baptiste amonique vous êtes
le maire de Villepreux également membre
du bureau de l'association des petites
villes de France et vous avez vous
copiloter le groupe de travail numéro 4
auprès du député des Hauts-de-Seine
pierre Cazeneuve un groupe de travail
qui portait sur la production de chaleur
et les énergies back carbone donc pour
répondre à de nombreuses questions sur
sur ce sujet d'importance on rappelle
les objectifs fixés c'est de réduire la
consommation d'énergie carbonée de 40%
d'ici à 2040 tout en développant dans le
même temps la consommation d'énergie
cette fois-ci décarbonée on parle d'un
gros défi on parle même du défi du
siècle pour pour ce sujet oui de toute
façon le défi énergétique le défi du
climat en règle générale pour nous doit
être la priorité vous l'avez dit c'est
le défi du siècle je crois qu'il faut
une mobilisation de tous les acteurs les
gouvernements les Etats les
collectivités les particuliers les
entreprises et on a réussi à démontrer
que c'était possible au moment où le
plan de se briété sobriété énergétique a
été enclenchée puisque grâce aux efforts
de tous nous avons réussi à diminuer de
10% notre consommation d'énergie
maintenant il faut passer de la sobriété
subit à la sobriété choisie l'efficacité
énergétique d'où cette loi qui a pour
objectif de planifier et de programmer
nos objectifs par ressources par énergie
par usage sur les prochaines décennies
et pourtant la rentrée on ne parle pas
de ce sujet on a parlé davantage de
laïcité on parle aussi d'une future loi
sur l'immigration on parle d'emploi on
parle aussi de numérique moins de
transition énergétique est-ce que ça
fait partie des priorités du
gouvernement peut-être qu'en cette
rentrée scolaire c'est le sujet de
l'inflation qui est le plus présent
après je pense qu'il ne faut pas opposé
fin du mois à fin du monde c'est
l'éternel débat non justement les
travaux engagés par la ministre Agnès
manière
ces groupes de travail et d'ailleurs je
salue la méthode parce que pour la
première fois on a une méthode de
co-construction qui implique des
parlementaires certes mais aussi des
élus locaux des associations d'élus les
collectivités donc les professionnels
des filières des secteurs des syndicats
et cela montre que le gouvernement est
pleinement et bien à la tâche pour
proposer un texte qui devrait arriver
prochainement au Parlement pour
planifier et programmer l'énergie du
pays sur les prochaines années on va
parler dans un instant de vos
principales conclusions je le disais sur
la forme vous avez copiloté ce groupe de
travail avec Pierre Cazeneuve député des
Hauts-de-Seine concrètement c'est un
travail qui a duré 4 mois qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pendant 4 mois alors ça a
été assez intensif on se connaissait pas
avec Pierre ça d'ailleurs été une belle
rencontre et on avait une douzaine de
participants dans notre groupe de
travail encore une fois les élus des
responsables et bien de filières etc et
nous avons auditionné plus d'une
trentaine d'acteurs des auditions des
déplacements de terrain aussi notamment
ici dans les Yvelines pour aller voir le
projet de géothermie à Auchère
Rocancourt pour aller voir aussi la
station géothermie à Vélizy alors on n'a
pas fait que de la géothermie puisque on
va peut-être l'évoquer il y a évidemment
plusieurs énergies qui ont été abordées
dans le cadre de notre groupe de travail
mais oui un gros travail de quatre mois
qui nous permet aujourd'hui de rendre un
certain nombre de pistes de réflexion
plutôt que des conclusions puisque après
ce sera à la ministre de son appareil si
elle le souhaite dans ce qui va être le
temps prochain de l'écriture de la loi
dans vos conclusions il y a notamment
l'une des énergies qui est revenue c'est
la biomasse si vous pouvez juste
rappeler ce comment fonctionne la
biomasse et je crois que c'est un sujet
d'ailleurs qui a suscité pas mal de
débats au sein de votre groupe de
travail alors nous on est parti d'un
constat très simple c'est que
aujourd'hui l'usage et l'énergie
électrique l'électricité
peut suffire à nous permettre d'être
autonome sur le plan énergétique et puis
surtout d'envisager la programmation
d'énergie pour les décennies à venir
donc nous nos préconisations sont
simples c'est d'accélérer partout c'est
possible sur les énergies renouvelables
et sur les énergies dites bas carbone
parmi elles la biomasse le sujet de la
biomasse on le sait c'est que ce n'est
pas une énergie et une ressource
extensible à souhait donc tout l'enjeu
et ça a été l'objet vous l'avez dit de
nombreux débats au sein de notre groupe
c'était de pouvoir quantifier et bien le
potentiel que consiste la biomasse et
surtout de pouvoir hiérarchiser
hiérarchiser pardon et prioriser en
fonction des usages nous ce qu'on attend
maintenant de la loi c'est qu'elle
puisse définir sur la ressource biomasse
notamment vers quels usages en la cible
en quelle proportion et avec des
échéances évidemment datées concrètement
la biomasse si on peut rappeler en quoi
ça consiste la biomasse est évidemment
issue au niveau des sols et notamment au
niveau de de de l'agriculture on a dû
auditionné d'ailleurs France bois et
forêt puisque c'est un acteur très
important maintenant il faut être assez
vigilant puisque l'idée c'est pas de
venir porter atteinte à notre
biodiversité et à notre patrimoine
naturel vous voulez aussi alors sur
cette question des énergies la mise en
place d'un plan national de la
géothermie vous avez parlé justement de
la géothermie avec des déplacements à
Vélizy au Chesnay Rocancourt également
ça consisterait en quoi ce plan national
alors déjà il faut rappeler que
aujourd'hui
40% 45% de notre consommation finale
d'énergie c'est la chaleur la chaleur
représente 45% et 24% aujourd'hui de
cette chaleur est perdue et non
renouvelable donc il faut maintenant
qu'on avance vers d'autres modèles de
production la géothermie est en est une
solution on a fait un certain nombre de
déplacements pour pouvoir concrètement
comment les collectivités s'emparer du
sujet il y a de beaux projets qui ont pu
voir le jour ou qui vont voir le jour
dans les Yvelines et effectivement nous
faisons cette proposition d'un plan
géoterminational concrètement ce que ça
veut dire c'est donner la possibilité
aux collectivités au territoire de
connaître l'état actuel de leur sous-sol
et de savoir si au niveau des gisements
au niveau des ressources et bien du du
sous-sol il y a des potentiels pour
pouvoir développer des projets
géothermiques en cette rentrée on parle
aussi notamment des prix des carburants
en matière de carburant très
spécifiquement quelles ont été vos
conclusions sur le sujet il va falloir
qu'on avance et qu'on accélère sur le
stockage et la logistique des
biocarburants on le voit aussi quand on
parle du gaz le sujet du gaz notamment
sur les réseaux c'est qu'il va falloir
que les réseaux demain puissent être
compatibles pour éventuellement avoir
d'autres types de gaz et d'autres types
évidemment et bien de ressources
maintenant il va falloir programmer les
choses il va falloir aussi que les
différents acteurs mettent la main à la
pâte puisque tout ça c'était aussi
l'objet du groupe de travail 7 il y a un
enjeu financier budgétaire il y aura des
arbitrages qui devront être faits plus
tard entre la ministre et son homologue
à Bercy Bruno Le Maire donc oui en tout
cas nous notre notre sujet est de dire
le nucléaire est une une mode de
production d'énergie dont nous ne
pouvons nous passer pour le moment
notamment sur la partie électricité
maintenant il faut développer toutes les
énergies renouvelables partout c'est
possible en ayant à l'esprit comme on
l'a dit pour la biomasse que certaines
ne sont pas extensibles à souhait et une
autre des conclusions c'est de renforcer
le rôle de l'ADEME alors on le rappelle
l'ADEME c'est une c'est l'agence du
développement durable on peut la
présenter
qu'est-ce que ça impliquerait aussi de
renforcer le rôle de la dame et pourquoi
vouloir renforcer son rôle alors nous
déjà on souhaiterait que dans un temps
très prochain son budget annuel soit
porté à un milliard avant d'atteindre
les 2,4 milliards d'ici 2030 l'ADEME on
a besoin de l'ADEME comme agent pilote
comme agence coordinatrice on va dire
d'un certain nombre de thématiques liées
à l'énergie c'est d'ailleurs la
proposition que nous ont pour la
biomasse que l'ADEME soit cette fameuse
agence qui puisse nous dire comment on
peut utiliser cette énergie cette
ressource en quelle proportion et il est
vrai aujourd'hui que l'ADEME pour nous
nous paraît être l'acteur le plus
important ça ça fait partie des
propositions assez innovantes que nous
faisons en espérant qu'elle soit suivie
maintenant du coup vient le temps pour
la ministre de la transition énergétique
de recueillir toutes ces conclusions
très concrètement pour les propositions
que vous avez pu faire avec votre groupe
de travail vous allez bon espoir qui est
soit retenu dans les laboration de la
future loi oui alors là on est vraiment
dans la phase préparatoire c'est à dire
que d'ailleurs encore une fois je salue
cette démarche de co-construction on a
fait un certain nombre de propositions
elles sont sur la table évidemment que
si nous avons eu la possibilité de les
présenter c'est que la ministre est
plutôt en soutien aux propositions que
nous avons formulées maintenant on sait
comment ça se passe le texte une fois
qui sera écrit va devoir aller au
Parlement à l'Assemblée au Sénat il va y
avoir la navette il va y avoir le
travail des commissions il y aura
peut-être des amendements moi j'espère
surtout que comme les deux textes
précédents qui ont touché l'énergie les
énergies renouvelables et la création de
PR notamment pour le pour le nucléaire
évidemment soit adopté j'espère que ce
ne sera pas un sujet qui sera utilisé à
des fins politiques aux politiciennes
par les oppositions
qu'on arrivera à se retrouver autour
d'une ambition commune puisqu'on l'a dit
en début d'entretien c'est le défi du
siècle et donc pouvoir programmer
planifier ce sont pas des gros mots au
contraire c'est un besoin vital pour
avoir une trajectoire très claire et
très précise pour la France sur le
calendrier ça paraît presque impossible
que ce texte arrive au Parlement d'ici
la fin de l'année du coup c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est 2024 ça je sais pas il
faudra voir avec les présidents des
chambres il y a LeBron Pivet et Gérard
Larcher bon en plus il y a un contexte
d'élection sénatoriale qui fait que il y
a un certain nombre de textes qui vont
peut-être être inscrits à l'ordre du
jour des chambres un peu plus tard en
tout cas si ce n'est pas fait avant la
fin 2023 ce sera fait début d'année 2024
mais moi j'ai bon espoir et puis on a la
chance d'avoir une ministre sur ce sujet
qui arrive aussi à faire consensus et à
trouver les arguments qui permettent
avec l'ensemble des acteurs autour de la
table d'avancer sur ce sujet important
un dernier mot un bilan plus personnel
sur ces quatre mois dans ce groupe de
travail alors vous avez participé on le
rappelle en tant que mère d'une commune
Villepreux mais aussi en tant que membre
du bureau de l'association des petites
villes de France passionnant très
stimulant sur le point sur le plan
intellectuel moi ce sont des sujets
évidemment qui me passionnent puisque à
Villepreux tout le projet de mandat a
été bâti autour des 17 objectifs de
développement durable il y a de
l'efficacité énergétique notamment sur
notre programme de rénovation du bâtis
scolaire je vais pas rentrer sur Tous
les programmes mais en tout cas ce sont
des thématiques pour moi qui sont très
importantes je souhaite porter des
politiques publiques justement qui
permettent de les accompagner ça a été
un gros travail là je vais dire que une
petite partie de mon agenda sur les
toutes prochaines semaines va un petit
peu s'aléléger parce qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé avec Pierre et les différents
membres du groupe de travail mais je
crois que c'était important de porter la
parole des territoires et je voudrais
peut-être conclure là dessus les
territoires aujourd'hui vont être
finalement les lieux où ces projets
d'énergie et d'énergie renouvelables
notamment vont voir le jour ça peut être
décidé au niveau de l'État mais c'est
bien des solutions concrètes sur les
territoires et bien qui vont s'engager
et donc ça ça ne pouvait pas se faire
sans les élus locaux et c'est la raison
pour laquelle avec petite ville de
France on a répondu présent à l'appel de
la ministre pour participer à ces
travaux merci Jean-Baptiste amonique
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ici
devant la mairie de Villepreux vous
l'aurez sans doute reconnu voilà c'est
la fin du 7 8 merci de nous avoir suivi
très belle soirée sur TV 78